cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com so we got the story from the
hill Biden Administration sending 800
new troops to border amid migrant crisis
we also have the uh Texas governor Greg
Abbott declaring an invasion he
previously declared an invasion he was
just reiterating that he had declared an
invasion and we recently learned that
the town of city of Eagle Pass I believe
the town declared an emergency 4 000
pirates in a single day
I got a lot of questions
it does feel perfect political timing
all of a sudden this news is back in in
place the election's coming up and now
we're getting big news about this why
why is is this like a legitimate Spike
that's just happening right now or has
this been going on for the past you know
two three years
go ahead on me I mean as somebody who's
who's been uh who traveled with a number
of the Caravans come up here no it's
going on for a while and when you ask
them why are you coming up now they will
tell you because Biden is president
this is what they'll tell you this is
what they told me I mean this is it this
could not be more obvious I mean just
look at the statistics when Trump was
President versus Biden right I mean this
is not debatable well they have those
shirts that like what is that please let
us in Biden or something like that those
yeah despite the Democrats living in
their alternative reality where they say
the border is closed we've closed the
border right isn't that what they say
all all day long I reckon yeah there's
there's a video where it looks like
border patrol agents opened the gates
let them in encounter them and then
close it and these are these are like
African migrants coming in that are
being welcomed in by U.S border Patrol
they're not protecting our borders
they're suing
putting up the buoys
on the U.S side how dare we what are we
doing here what are we doing I look at
the end of the day they they still
believe despite what we talked about
before where they're making a mistake in
terms of how this is going to work out
generationally for them they still think
this is the best tactic to lock in
generational Democratic votes by letting
everybody in look I did a video I did a
video one time where I walked around and
I asked the left and I said is having a
border racist and they all said yes it's
racist to have a border because you're
not allowing brown people into the
country now ironically when I went
across the border and I asked the
migrants is it wrong for America to have
a border they go no were you crazy like
I want to be here you need to try to
stop me like they get it take a look at
this story from the New York Post Biden
secretly has let 221 456 migrants fly
into the US in the past year
how is it that we're getting a story
that is sending troops to the Border but
he's also letting them all come in it
sounds like it's fake news like or it's
just it's a virtual signal it's a virtue
signal because they're getting hammered
by Eric Adams and hocal and a lot of
these uh Sanctuary City jurisdiction
left-leaning politicians and they are
they are in need of some sort of gesture
that they can point to that they've been
heard but you don't need to look any
farther than the CBP one app that our
own Department of Homeland Security
developed to ensure that there was a
orderly and appropriate passageway for
people into our country without too much
paperwork and it was immediately hacked
by the cartels and totally utilized by
the cartels to move their own people
into the country so we literally built
an app for the cartels
so that there wouldn't be too much you
know bureaucratic uh bureaucratic
challenge for them so long was it hacked
before they realized it had been hacked
oh I mean it was it was within a matter
of week wow and they were just being
used to like organize yeah well the
cartel would wall off any any any claims
that weren't the claims into the system
that they had managed controlled and and
monetized what's what's the Florida
sentiment right I know there's a lot of
uh Cubans and Venezuelans who escaped
communism and they come to Florida and
we also know that Florida has a huge
swing towards Republicans in the past
election cycle I'm curious like what's
what's it like on the ground for regular
people how do they feel about the
illegal immigration well it turns out in
Florida we actually have enough people
coming to our state just from other
states within the United States you know
we we've got the uh migrants from uh
Illinois and uh New York and California
uh there there is a new law that
Governor DeSantis and our legislature
put into effect that creates
consequences for people and that ensures
that people are held until the ice
detainers are executed on uh and it's
not just going to be released into our
community and we've actually had a lot
of successful self-deport station in
recent months in Florida where people
who are there illegally are getting up
and leaving I know that because I've had
construction companies and lawn care
companies called me and say what the
heck this this new law in our state is
causing all my workers to leave and
there will be some short-term pain when
we ultimately reshape our economy around
the American Experience not just
exploiting people who come here that you
can pay under the table it's the drugs
man it's the it's the figurative
economic drugs of they they want cheap
labor to come in but then they create
industry that becomes dependent upon it
and then you become the bad guy for
trying to solve the problem you say we
got it we got to deal with illegal
immigration and all of a sudden oh no
I'm losing my my cheap under the table
workers it's your fault I don't I don't
remember I mean there's kids in cages
now but I don't recall
um AOC drifting in crying wearing white
like a bartending Specter crying about
keeping kids in cages in the last couple
years
it's called Uh because when it was
Donald Trump we had cages for for these
children and children were put in cages
but as soon as uh Biden came in we
replaced the cages in name and now we
call them safety facilities that's right
but the word safety say yes once you use
the word safety that means you can do
anything you want don't tell McCarthy
it'll be the safety continuing
resolution
or the Patriot continuing resolution and
by the way one of the games I I I I've
now see the people on the left doing and
is that they go well we we send them
into the interior of the country but the
majority of people come back for their
court case now by the way technically
that's true through but the reason why
that's true is because they know you get
two right the first one they come back
for because I know they get an appeal
they never come back for the second one
they come back but they never that left
never mentions the second one they only
mentioned the first one statistically
because they're right because that's the
argument now no no no no you can let
them in they all come back for their
court case
unreal it's the it's the it's very dark
in my mind when I think about excessive
immigration what it's done to countries
in the past what it's done to empires in
the past when it did to Rome are we all
thinking about the Romans hyper
accelerated the fall of the Empire like
no I was thinking of the UK
what what's the status yeah in the UK
what immigration has done to that
country has been devastating to their
economy to their social experience it's
been rough France better Germany is
better Sweden
Nordic socialist economies all the all
the folks that were displaced from the
wars in the Middle East ended up working
their way kind of up up uh through
Europe and into this benefit structures
the funny thing about the the
Scandinavian countries is how Norway was
a bit more based and Sweden was a bit
more woke Norway was like we will
absolutely release all the stats on
crime demographics age Etc Sweden was
like we're not going to do that and so
what would happen is people in Sweden
would look at Norway because it's
extremely comparable and be like yeah we
know our government's lying to us in
Denmark when you're trying to get on the
train to Mama you got to give you you
got to give your ID because they're very
concerned it's the it's the Danish
they're super concerned about what's
going on Sweden they don't care so
Sweden used to when they released the
crime statistics they did release the
demographics of the crime statistics
they stopped doing right
yep I'm looking at the lamp into the
city country that Italian island that's
been overrun by Tunisian and migrants
like 13 000 tunisians just around this
island of 6 000 people or something
Francis said yesterday they're not going
to welcome the migrants that are in
lampedusa uh Poland accused the EU of
encouraging human trafficking for
allowing this to happen
um they are the traffickers kick them
off the uh off uh Tunisia off the coast
and then it's uh it's military and and
uh ngos that come pick them up it's all
human trafficking so when I I actually
went on the raft with the Syrian uh
migrants from Turkey to Greece wow how
long was that at that super short right
it might be three hours you could see
let's see Greece yeah you can see Greece
when you take off I watch people swim
you're in my crazy yeah we have very
different type of trips to the
Mediterranean I remember when I when I
was having a discussion on my first you
know because people were dying on this
trip oh so I had a conversation with the
um with the Coast Guard you at New York
coast guard I said I need a little bit
of device and they go one I go well I
need to know what it's like if I'm going
on this rafting trip across the ocean
across the the the uh Adriatic to to
Greece they go okay you're kidding
around I'm like no I'm serious like okay
here's the things that you need so I
needed a a type 2 life jacket makes
sense the kind of thing if you lose
Consciousness it keeps you your face up
you needed a strobe light also made
sense you know in case you're in the
thing
um you need a flare gun took all these
things made total sense then they said
you need a uh a knife so I said okay I'm
assuming that's because if I get caught
in the rigging I can cut myself no no no
he's like they're all going to try to
steal your life jacket and you have to
stab your way out of it wow and he goes
and the one last thing you need you
ready for this condoms I go look man I'm
a red-blooded American but I think I
could hold myself on a three hour rap
product no no if you do lose your life
jacket if you blow up condoms and put
them under your arm it'll give you maybe
10-15 minutes of extra time
so uh check out this map you want to
pull this up Carter this is uh this is
Greece and uh this is lesvos you can see
it's it's it's super close to Turkey
so all the migrants are coming here
there's migrant camps and then that's
Greece so once you're in Greece there's
a ferry that goes straight to Athens
but you're as you're talking about it's
all trafficking for me to get on this
raft I had to deal with the Turkish
Mafia yeah they controlled the entire
thing and by the way it's not cheap that
was a it was 2 000 Euros if you're a
migrant to get to let to get a seat on
this thing I don't like I don't even
know where they're coming
I'll tell you I interviewed I've
interviewed two brothers who uh one
brother left before the war got really
bad went to Romania and got uh I don't
know if they got citizenship he got like
uh he got a refugee status so it allowed
him travel to the Schengen Zone allowed
him to work and he was living a good
life doing uh computer graphic design
stuff his brother stayed behind then
eventually Europe closes it closes off
saying like no we can't take any more
refugees so he tries to get on a raft
from Izmir to lesvos and he's a he's a
young man who has money and works he
saves it up this is not so I mean this
is someone fleeing War for sure but they
have money it's not like it's just
people living in rubber but they're not
they're not see here's the thing they're
not fleeing War well this guy they're
not going from Syria they're going from
Turkey they're already once they're in
Turkey right you're not feeling more
anymore right right now we're just
talking about I want an upgrade on my
life conditions right that's the only
issue they're not leaving from Syria to
get away they're already safe physically
in Turkey I completely agree because in
a way
to leverage the west and the EU has been
pretty masterful right whenever he seeks
some concession you know he threatens to
have some massive release out of turkey
and uh whenever he gets what he wants
he'll sort of constrain those releases
and so it's become a geopolitical he's a
weapon he's weaponized it for sure
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time